kim kardashian sure did bring the laughs
for her snl debut i think you have to
have a sense of humor and thanks to the
reality star's close friend tracy
romulus we've got a behind the scenes
look at kim's musical comeback in honor
of kim's 41st birthday on thursday tracy
shared this moment of kim recording her
vocals for the show's music video
[Music]
tracy shared another backstage moment we
see kim rehearsing for a sketch that
didn't make it to the broadcast but it
now has over three million views on
snl's youtube page peanut brittle in
bulk aquarium rocks
humidifiers
and a can of tuna that's one foot tall
but of course this wasn't the business
mogul's first time at the microphone
kim recorded the dance club single jam
turn it up in 2011. we would play it in
vegas when we were in the clubs like
turn on kim's song that's like the one
thing i'm like i can't believe i did
that and she later took part in this
family jam sesh as a birthday gift for
mom kris jenner we're gonna party till
we just can't party no more and speaking
of b-day tributes you know what i don't
need anything for my birthday well too
late kim because your famous fam shared
some heartfelt messages to instagram
along with some classic throwback pics
courtney wrote happy birthday to my
built-in best friend
and baby sis kendall said best buddies
since the day i popped out while kim's
iconic momager reminded her you are in
the prime of your life with four
beautiful children and living your best
life
[Music]
you